These are the red flags that tell
readers and editors that you don't know
what you're doing. Because good writing
is like good design. When it works, it's
invisible. But once there's a problem,
it's all your readers can see. And it
undermines your credibility and your
entire message. So, in this video, I'm
going to reveal the seven mistakes that
I always come across in the first round
of feedback on essays and other
non-fiction so that you can just skip
the writing consultation and edit it
yourself. And don't worry about taking
any notes because I'm giving you my
sevenstep diagnostic checklist. It's the
one I use with all my clients whenever
we're reviewing their work. But you can
just have it for free so you can just
print it off and tape it up on your desk
wall. But first, to understand what a
big change this new way of editing is,
you need to understand what I call the
coffee stain problem. So, imagine you've
written a first draft and now you're
looking it over, checking for mistakes
and improving the writing before you
publish. As you're revising, you knock
over your coffee cup and stain the page.
From this point on, that coffee stain is
going to remind you of that time and
place, but it won't mean anything to
your readers. And that's exactly what
happens with the old way of editing.
Your words are like coffee stains that
only make sense to you. I mean, think
about it. When you were writing those
sentences, you were trying to express an
idea that you already had in your head.
So naturally, when you see those words
again, they are going to trigger the
memory of that idea. So the problem here
is that this is association, not
communication. If you actually want your
writing to make it off the page and into
the mind of your reader, then you need
to know consciously what your readers
expect intuitively. And that's what this
sevenstep process is going to help you
do. So without any further ado, I'm now
going to show you my sevenstep editing
system. And for the first part, if
you've ever written something great,
something you're really proud of and
watched it underperform, this is for
you. Because I have found the most
common error that makes quality ideas
flounder isn't with the writing itself.
It's one step before that. It's with the
person who's reading it. So, for
example, imagine you had a friend whose
pet died and another friend turns to
them and says, "Oh, never mind. You can
always get another pet." If you look at
that sentence and you judge it based on
the content itself, it doesn't tell you
anything about whether it's a good
sentence or a bad sentence. The point
here is that writing is really weird.
Like it's this solitary act. Okay, we
sit alone in a room and we get these
ideas and we try to express those ideas
and it's this weird moment where we're
using language which is social. Language
is always social, but when we're
writing, we're having to use it in this
asocial situation. So, the first mistake
that always happens is that writers lose
sight of their readers. And if that
advice sounds common enough, what I
really want you to think about is not
only who is your reader, but what do
they want and what do they need? So, the
advice here is to know your reader and
not just your audience. What decisions
are they trying to make? Like what
motivated them to click on your
headline, to read this article? What
problem are they dealing with? What
answer are they looking for? What
decision are they trying to make? These
four questions help you get a concrete
profile of your reader. And whenever
writers bring their text to me, I don't
even look at it before answering these
questions because you can't really make
decisions about whether a text is
successful. Just like the friend who
gives the bad advice to the other friend
whose pet died, you can't judge the
success of an article based on the text
alone. You need to know who it the text
is responding to. And so these four
questions give you a profile, a relevant
profile of your reader. Now, for the
second point, believe it or not, your
most important ideas are often dying a
slow death in the place where readers
least expect to find them. The problem
here is that when you're writing
valuable non-fiction, you're using the
text differently than your reader is.
All right? Writers use the text to solve
a problem. So, what you do is you start
off with a question. You bring in your
evidence and you start to do the kind of
intellectual work, working your way
through it piece by piece until
ultimately you come to a point of
satisfaction, resolve, and that is when
you stop writing. That's what we call
writing patterns. But the problem here
is that your reader doesn't use writing
patterns. Your reader uses reading
patterns. And if you don't know how to
fix the text to match their reading
patterns, you cause interference, which
means you basically make the reader have
to dig through a pile of information in
order to find the ideas that they're
looking for. So either you're creating
more work for them or they're just going
to abandon the text altogether. But when
you fix this, you make it a lot easier
for readers to know immediately whether
your piece is worth their time. And even
speed readers and skimmers are going to
get your message. For an example of this
difference between writing patterns and
reading patterns, imagine that you're at
a restaurant and your friend calls you
asking for directions cuz they're going
to come and meet you. What do you tell
them? Well, if you're like most writers,
you're going to describe your own route.
You'll say something like, "Well, I
started from my apartment, went down
Fifth Street, hit some traffic near the
mall, took a detour through the
residential area, and then finally found
parking two blocks away, and walked
over." Now, no grammar mistakes in that
passage. A+ if you run it through
Grammarly. But does it work? Well, that
route only works if your friend is
starting from your apartment. But if
they're coming from across town from
their apartment, then this passage is
completely useless to them. And the
thing is, your writing works exactly the
same way. When you're writing, it's an
extension of your thinking. So your best
ideas usually come at the end after
you've worked them out. But you can't
just give that to readers. When you bury
your main point at the end or in the
middle of your paragraph after walking
readers through your entire thinking
process, you're giving them your route
to the restaurant, not theirs. So, in a
different context, instead of writing
something like, "After analyzing market
conditions, reviewing competitor
strategies, examining consumer trends,
and evaluating financial projections, I
recommend we launch the new product
line." You could try something more like
this. We should launch a new product
line. Here's why. Market conditions are
favorable, competitors are vulnerable,
consumer trends support it, and
financial projections show strong
returns. In the first version, readers
have to follow your entire intellectual
journey before discovering whether it
was worth their time. But in the second
version, they immediately know your
destination and then they can decide
whether they want to take that trip with
you. So, the point here is to lead with
the main point. How do you do that?
Well, whenever you're reviewing your
draft, look for the one sentence that
you need readers to accept, act upon, or
use. Usually, you'll be able to find
that at the end of the text because
that's where you usually discover it.
Other times, it can be buried in the
middle of a paragraph somewhere. But the
point here is that when you find it, you
need to move it to the end of your
introduction, not the conclusion.
Because reading is a time investment. So
in your professional writing, readers
need to know what your point is
immediately before they decide whether
they're going to invest the time in the
rest of the passage. So when you put the
main point first, not last, you create
the right expectations. But it's not
enough to just put your ideas where your
readers expect to find them. Because
honestly, readers don't care about your
ideas. They care about their problems.
Many writers make the mistake of giving
readers information that they didn't ask
for instead of solutions to problems
that they have. This is when readers
think to themselves, why are you telling
me this? So, to see how this plays out,
imagine the following situation. Let's
say that you need to write an op-ed and
your goal is to convince university
administrators to control the campus
squirrel population. These squirrels
have been running a muk. You know that
some readers are going to resist this
idea. So, here's how most writers would
start. Most students think the squirrels
are adorable. However, we need to
control the squirrel population. All
right. What just happened here? You
basically said, "I know, I know you love
these fluffy creatures, but we're going
to get rid of them anyway." And your
reader's thinking, "Oh, great. Another
squirrel killer, and now they're going
to reject everything you say." So, you
try again with the following opening.
Most students think squirrels are
adorable. However, our study shows 70%
of campus squirrels carry viruses. Well,
that's better, right? Wrong. because now
your reader is thinking, "Okay,
squirrels are adorable and they carry
viruses. So what? They're still cute."
In other words, you haven't actually
challenged anything that would prevent
them from rejecting your proposal. But
what if you tried an opening like this?
Most students think that adorable
squirrels are harmless. However, our
study shows 70% carry viruses
communicable to humans. Now you're
getting somewhere. You're speaking
directly to the squirrel lovers and
you're addressing their concerns and
showing them that there's something
missing or misguided about their
beliefs. So, what's the difference here?
Your reader thinks that squirrels are
cute. They are resistant to your idea
that we should get rid of them. So, in
the first version, you ignored their
resistance. In the second version, you
gave them information that didn't
address their resistance. But in the
third version, you identified the
specific belief that's actually standing
in the way of your solution and you
dismantled it. So this third version is
an effective introduction because it
sets up the right motivation. So here's
how you can use your introduction to
create that kind of motivation for your
readers. Start with a problem that your
readers recognize. Do not begin with
background information because
ultimately what we're trying to do here
is to frame your ideas as the solution
to a problem that matters to your
readers. Okay? We don't just want to
give them information. We want to give
your idea in the context of a problem
that they care about. So how do you get
them to care about the problem? It
depends on your reader. And in this
case, you basically have three kinds of
readers. All right? Uninformed readers
are people who don't know about the
problem. So in that case, you're going
to need to provide some background to
help them see that problem and its
stakes. A second kind of reader is an
indifferent reader. Those are ones who
know about the problem but just don't
care about it. And so in that case you
present them with the problem but you
need to establish the consequences of
not solving that problem and make those
consequences directly relevant to that
reader. And a third kind of reader is a
resistant reader. And so in that case
they know about the problem they know
about your solution and they don't like
your solution. So in that case you need
to speak their language. All right? So
you want to acknowledge their position
and then present that position in a way
that makes it seem less stable for them.
So they recognize some inadequacy or
something missing or something broken
with their current position. So that way
they perceive your ideas as something
that will make their position more
stable. Now that you've got them through
the introduction, you still need to help
readers move through your key ideas. But
honestly, if you want to make your essay
easy to follow, there's a simple writing
hack that I can't believe nobody else is
talking about. I've seen a lot of
writing teachers online tell writers to
avoid repetition and redundancy and
instead to use variation. And I don't
know where these people are getting this
information. It sounds like something
from our grade school grammar class. The
problem with this variation is that it
confuses readers either by introducing
too many things at once or by using
different words to refer to the same
concept. That makes it really difficult
for readers to follow. It makes your
text feel scattered and unfocused. So
whenever I explain this idea in my
creative non-fiction writing class, I
usually ask students to imagine their
text as a play or a musical, right? one
with characters on the stage, right?
These writers are telling you to vary to
to not repeat yourself, but that's like
introducing all these different
characters onto the scene. To the
contrary, you want to limit your focus
to only a few select characters. Really,
you're going to have primarily one
character. But when you're using this
kind of variability, your text becomes
incoherent. It becomes like a scene in a
play that has all these different
characters talking. And when you're
sitting in the audience or when you're
reading the words, like you can
understand the words that are being
spoken by the characters, but if you
zoom out and consider the meaning of
that scene as a whole, you can't really
say what it's about. In a good play or
musical, each of these scenes has a
clear main character. And while there
might be other characters coming in to
interact with them, those are secondary
characters and they're using to draw out
different aspects of this primary focus.
So similarly, in a coherent text,
there's going to be a clear subject and
the other characters are going to step
in as concepts to help develop that
subject through comparison and contrast.
But at the end of it, there's no doubt
in the mind of the reader what the
passage is about. So in your non-fiction
writing, the way to build coherence is
through key terms. So most professional
writing fails because it's about too
many things at once. So if you want to
make your writing coherent, then you
need to make it about something specific
and then stick to it. So So the way to
do that is choose your section, you
know, whether it's a paragraph or a
section. Identify the major key terms
that readers need to accept in this.
Track these terms from beginning to end
and use the same words or closely
related synonyms. Now, when you come to
the fifth point, we're now starting to
clarify your text. And when people talk
about clear writing, they're really
talking about one thing. People talk
about clarity in writing like it's this
elusive thing or it's a god-given gift.
But honestly, it's really just a matter
of one simple sentence trick. And
whenever you ignore this trick, readers
have a variety of words that they use to
describe this kind of writing, right?
The writing is dull, passive, unclear,
indirect, and abstract. But if you think
about like if you look at these words,
they're not very helpful, are they? All
they do is they tell us the way readers
feel when they read this sentence or
this passage, but it doesn't actually
tell us what's wrong with the writing.
So when you ignore this sentence trick,
it makes your writing sound detached and
academic and your ideas sound
theoretical and abstract rather than
valuable and useful. But when you follow
this principle in your writing, suddenly
it becomes grounded in the real world.
And this is what readers call vigorous,
active, direct, clear, concrete. And to
understand it, we're going to continue
with the metaphor that we developed in
the last section. This idea of being in
the audience and watching a play or a
musical on the stage. All right? If
that's true, then at the grammar level,
the subject in terms of subject, verb,
object, the subject is the spotlight.
It's what identifies the main character
of the scene. Right? So, take a look at
these two sentences. As a writing
teacher, they're my favorite sentences.
All right? So, we have the dog chased
the cat and the cat was chased by the
dog. Which sentence is better? There are
honestly some writing teachers who will
tell you that sentence one is better
than sentence two. But I'm here to tell
you that it all depends on what you care
about and what you think your reader
cares about. If you care about the cat,
then sentence one is less valuable to
you because it's shining the spotlight
on something that you don't care about.
Right? So, what we're talking about with
this spotlight is this idea of focus.
You want to focus on what really matters
in your sentence. And so to create that
focus, what you do is put the people,
the companies, or even the concepts or
ideas that your readers care about in
the subject position of your sentence.
And when you follow this principle so
that you have a consistent element in
the subject position across a series of
sentences, it becomes a focus or point
of view, a consistent place where the
reader is looking. Like when you vary
the subject across a bunch of sentences,
it's like the spotlight is moving
around. So ideally, you want to be
intentional about what you put in the
subject position and try to maintain
consistency for as long as is necessary.
Find the characters that your readers
actually care about and put them in the
subject position. But it's not enough to
just have all these clear sentences laid
out in a sequence. Because if smart
people feel stupid when they're reading
your writing, the problem isn't their
intelligence, it's your writing. A big
problem that I often find whenever I'm
reviewing first drafts is that writers
are making their readers work too hard
to understand how the ideas connect with
each other. Now, as an editor, I'll do
the work to untangle this stuff and
figure out how these ideas relate to
each other. But in practice, what
happens is readers give up before they
even understand your ideas because
processing your writing is just mentally
taxing. But when you implement this
simple step, your writing becomes
effortless to read. Your complex ideas
feel clear and logical, and readers can
focus on your ideas instead of
struggling with your sentences. And I
think the best way to understand this is
with the following joke from Jerry
Stiller.
>> All right, here's a joke. Okay, newly
weds, they go straight from the ceremony
into the limousine that's going to take
them to the cruise ship that's going to
take them around the world on their
honeymoon. Suddenly, the husband says,
"You know, sweetheart, I forgot to get
condoms. It's a little too soon for us
to start a family, don't you think? I
mean, it's a it's a honeymoon." So, he
tells the limo driver to stop off at the
first drugstore. As he gets out, he
says, "Oh, by the way, darling, do you
need anything?" She says, "Yes, you can
get me some Dramamine, you know, in case
I get seasick, Melameir." So he goes in,
he says to the guy, "I'd like the
biggest box of condoms he got and some
Dramamine." The guy looks at him and
says, "Do you mind if I ask you a
question?" He says, "Not at all." He
says, "If it makes you nauseous, why do
you do it?"
>> And so the reason this joke works is
because when you present two items side
by side, readers automatically assume
that there's some logical relationship
between them. Right? This is known in
linguistics, if you're interested, as
Grace's maxims. Readers always assume
that there's some logical relationship
between two things that are presented
side by side. So, if you don't specify
that relationship, then they're not
going to shrug their shoulders and say,
"Oh, I guess there's no relationship."
They're going to assume that there's a
relationship, right? So, if you don't
want to make readers guess how your
ideas connect with each other, then
there are two things you can do. One,
you want to create clear logical bridges
between your ideas. These are words like
because, therefore, however, and
although and these words or phrases,
connectors show cause and effect,
conditions, contrasts, comparison, etc.
And second, you want to make sure that
the actions are represented as verbs and
not nouns. And combining step five with
step six, now you have what are called
cores, right? You have clear characters
in the subject position and you've got
clear actions in the verb. That's a core
clause. And then you use these logical
bridges to specify the logical
relationships between those cores. And
with this last step, you are not ready
to hit publish yet because if you were
to publish now, it would be like putting
on a fancy suit and leaving your fly
down. Sloppy presentation undermines
your credibility. Now, nothing builds
trust with a serious reader like a razor
sharp dead to rights sentence. And
nothing breaks that trust like typos and
formatting errors. They make you look
careless. And so, this seventh and last
step is what you would normally think of
whenever you think of proofreading,
right? You're going to edit for
mechanics, polish for professionalism.
You clean up the grammar, punctuation,
spelling, formatting. But you have to
remember that this is the last step, not
the first. Most people obsess over
grammar, looking for mistakes when their
writing serves no clear purpose for
their readers. So, if you've completed
the first six steps and you want to edit
for mechanics, then all you really need
to do is proofread for grammar,
punctuation, spelling. Of course, you
can use online tools for this, but I
really don't think there's any
substitute for a writer or an editor's
keen eye for these things. Now, you also
want to check for house style,
particularly if you're submitting for
publication in another journal. But even
if you're publishing on your own
platform, on a platform like Substack or
something like that, there are certain
conventions that aren't going to be
written in any rule book, but that you
want to reproduce in your text so that
it uh seems appropriate within the
genre. And of course, you just want to
think about things like presentation
online. That could be things like the
the markup and the uh formatting of your
web page. If you're publishing in print,
then that's things like spacing,
margins, you know the drill. But the
point here is to make sure that you do
all of this after you've solved these
bigger problems of purpose and structure
because most professional writing fails
because it serves the writer instead of
the reader. But if you grab the
sevenstep checklist linked down below
the like button, you'll be able to
transform your ideas into writing that
solves reader problems and delivers
actual value. But in the age of AI, this
kind of writing is a dying art. So to
learn about my plugandplay system for
writing without AI, watch this video
next because it's going to take you from
idea to manuscript with each step all
mapped out with clear, actionable
advice. So be sure to go check it out.